let's do some more work with rational
expressions so let's say i had a squared
plus
2 a
b
plus b squared and all of that
is over
a
b squared
minus
a squared b and we're going to take this
and divide it by
we're going to divide it by
a plus b
divided by a plus b so the first thing
we might want to do is just factor this
numerator and this denominator and then
we could divide or actually we could go
the other way we could divide and then
factor so if we divide and then factor
we could say well this is the same thing
this is equal to this whole expression
let me just copy and paste it that's
probably the easiest thing to do
let me copy and then paste it
it's equal to that expression
times the inverse of this if i divide by
something that's the same thing
that's the same thing as multiplying by
the inverse as multiplying by 1 over 8
plus b and this is just going to be the
same thing as
this is going to be the same thing as
that
with a plus b in the denominator because
your numerator is going to be that times
1 which is just that your denominator is
going to be a b squared minus a squared
b times a plus b so that
times a plus b so this would be a
legitimate answer but i have a suspicion
that this can be further simplified so
let's see if we can simplify it so our
numerator our numerator here a squared
plus 2a b plus b squared you might
recognize that that is a perfect square
that is our numerator let me color code
it
so that numerator right there
that is the same thing as
a
plus b
squared or a plus b times a plus b
because you have a squared you have a b
squared and then you have 2 times a and
b right in the middle that is a perfect
square multiply it out if you don't
believe me so that numerator is that
right there and then the denominator
the denominator what is this well let's
see if what happens if we factor out an
a b down here
so let's factor out an a b
so a b squared divided by a b
a cancels out you're just left with a
b
right a b times b is a b squared
and then minus a squared b divided by a
b
is just a
is just an a
this right here
is the same thing as that and you could
multiply it out a b times negative a is
negative a squared b you got that right
there so multiply it out you should get
this right there and of course you also
have your a plus b sitting here
now we have an a plus b squared in the
numerator we have an a plus b in the
denominator we could say a plus b to the
first power and then we know our
exponent rules here we can just
essentially cancel out an a plus b in
the numerator and the denominator which
decrements this exponent by one so this
just becomes a one and then this becomes
a zero or it cancels out
and so we get this is being equal to
a plus b
over over
a
b
over a b times
minus a
with the caveat because we cancelled
this thing out in the denominator we
have to say look this thing can still
not equal 0 because this will still make
this expression undefined we have to say
the only way that this is going to be
equal to 0 is if we subtract b from both
sides a is equal to negative b so we
have to add the caveat that a cannot be
equal to negative b we have to add this
condition
and so this
is our answer let's do another one
let's say i have
let's say we can do a let's do a more
involved one just to really get our
juices flowing let's say we have x
squared
x squared
plus
x
plus sixteen
divided by
or over
seven x squared plus nine
x
plus two
divided by
7 x
over
x squared
plus
x
so what is this going to be equal to so
here we could divide first that's the
same thing as multiplying by the inverse
of this thing but just for fun let's
factor these two the numerator and the
denominator here
so this numerator over here that's
pretty straightforward that is a perfect
square that is x plus 4 squared 4 times
4 is 16
4 plus 4 is 8. so our numerator is x
plus
x plus 4
squared
and then our denominator
our denominator what does that become
here we're gonna have to do a little bit
of grouping we're gonna have to do a
little bit of grouping to factor that
out so we have seven x squared plus nine
x
plus two we have to find two numbers
when i multiply them i get 7 times 2
which is equal to 14 and when i add them
a plus b needs equal 9. and the easiest
two numbers are 7 and 2.
so let's rewrite this this is the same
thing as seven x squared i'll group the
seven x with the seven because i have a
common factor of seven
plus seven x plus two x
plus two
put parentheses around there so you can
see the grouping factor out a seven x
over here you get seven x
times x plus one
plus factor out a two here two times
x plus one
and you get the seven x plus two
7 x plus 2
times
times your x plus 1. we're
undistributing
that expression so this is our
denominator right there
this is our denominator
so and actually i just realized that i
made a slight error when i wrote down
this problem the numerator here is
actually 7x plus 2 lucky for us
obviously this is going to
lead to interesting things later on
potentially so let's see what we get
and actually i think there's a typo here
i think this is supposed to be a 4x
or sorry just a 4. so let me just put it
like that just just in case that is a
typo because i think it's going to make
it more interesting so that's our
original problem we haven't messed with
this part yet so it won't change any of
our math but so far we factored this
bottom part we factored this bottom part
using grouping as 7x plus 2
times
x plus 1. and so this expression is the
exact same thing as this expression over
here and we're going to divide it by
that expression
so dividing
by that expression that is the same
exact thing as multiplying by the
inverse of this expression by the
inverse of this expression oh actually
you know what i just realized that it
wasn't x squared plus 4x i just saw the
problem that is an x squared plus 4x so
this was the original problem sorry for
all of that but we haven't done any work
here so it's all cool
so
this right over here
multiplying by the inverse of this we
multiply dividing by this is the same
thing as multiplying by the inverse so
we just flip the numerator and
denominator so x squared plus four x
over
seven
x
plus
two
and then another thing we can do let's
see if we look at this up here we can
factor out an x so this right here if we
factor out an x is the same thing as x
times x plus
4. so if we do all of the multiplication
what does our numerator become we have
x let me do a new color
we have
x plus four squared
times x
times x plus four that is our numerator
and our denominator is seven x plus two
times another seven x plus two
times an x plus one
so here nothing is cancelling out but we
have the term the same term being
multiplied multiple times
x to the fourth squared times x to the
fourth to the first power this is going
to be equal to we still have our x out
front so it's x times
x plus 4 we could say to the third power
all of that over we have two seven x's
plus two so seven x
plus two
squared times
x plus one and we are done